hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of Game of Thrones season seven episode
five east watch an episode where the
riders per like wheeling out like ten
episodes left in this series we gotta
just quickly teleport all of our
characters where they need to be yeah
forget greyscale George gonna need a
cure for jet lag so let's take a cue
from the show and not waste any time and
let's just dive right into it okay let's
start with our opening images this
episode begins where the last episode
left off with bran and Jamie in
Blackwater rush washing up on a shore
after the battle now some of you pointed
this out of the visuals of Jamie's
sinking underwater was similar to his
brother Tyrion sinking in season five in
the waters by the doom of Valyria and
now Bronn pulls Jaime ashore just like
how Jorah saved Tyrion and it's
interesting that this episode begins
with this sub old family connection now
this episode is technically titled
Eastwatch but that was a new name that
was changed from the original name which
was blood of the Dragon and I'm thinking
that the writer of this episode intended
on blood of the dragon being the title
that reflected the real theme of this
episode actually in the scene Jaime
invokes this phrase Doubront are you
doing that oh my god
Jaime is saying that he wanted to
literally spill the blood of the dragon
but looking at this phrase more deeply
blood of the dragon refers to the idea
of family bloodlines being a source of
power for all these characters and I
will come back to this idea as we go on
okay moving on to Tyrion walking through
the ashy aftermath of drogon torching
all the Lannister soldiers notice this
corpse still hiding behind his shield
this is a historical reference to the
archaeological remains of the victims of
Pompeii the ancient Italian city that
was destroyed by the volcano Mount
Vesuvius in 79 AD and many of those
corpses were found in the exact pose
that they were in the moment of their
deaths
now when Daenerys makes her speech to
the surviving Lannisters and tarly's
notice her line here and all I want to
destroy is the wheel that is rolled over
rich and poor to the benefit of no one
but the sassy Lannister's of the world
this is actually a callback to Daenerys
his promise to Tyrion back in season
five Lannister Targaryen Baratheon stark
Tyrell they're all just spokes on a
wheel
this one's on tops and that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing the
on the ground I'm not going to stop the
wheel I'm going to break the wheel here
Daenerys is hoping that metaphor will
work on all these ponds who have been
dying for this conniving Queen who
doesn't care about them but that
inspirational approach fades pretty
quickly notice how only a few men kneel
when Danny makes her speech but way more
kneel to the threat of drogon so once
again be late Elena Tyrells wisdom is
coming true
remember in Episode two she warned
Daenerys that ear is a more powerful
motivator than love of course I can't
remember a queen who was better loved
and my granddaughter
the common people loved her the nobles
loved her what is left of her now ashes
they won't obey you unless they fear you
but really neither these tactics work on
Randall and dicken Tarly actually notice
their armor here it's covered in ash but
there are fresh blood stains on top so
even after drogon dropped in and started
turning all their men into ash these two
still fought bravely and took down some
of the Dothraki with it now of course
Danny's decision to burn this father and
son alive makes her parallel to her
father the Mad King he burned Ned
Stark's father ricard and his older
brother Brandon with wildfire and very
sexually describes the horror of
witnessing this exact event in detail
later this episode when the hair caught
fire and the smell of the burning flesh
filled a throne room I'm not the one
doing it now yes it's true that Daenerys
might be embracing Elena's advice to be
the dragon a little too much here but I
would say this is Daenerys his only
option unlike her father she wasn't just
torturing these men for fun she's
delivering on a promise that she made
very clear to them actually there's
another past character that Daenerys is
more closely following the footsteps of
who I think she should be more careful
about not repeating his mistakes Stannis
Baratheon let's actually take a moment
to look at all the ways this episode
makes these two characters parallel one
they are both ambitious rightful
monarchs anxiously biding their time on
Dragonstone as they explored options to
invade Westeros mainland to at this
point they had both suffered major naval
defeats three they both burn people who
don't bend the knee to them Dany burned
the tarly's just like Stannis burned
mance rayder
actually while we're on this subject
remember last episode Daenerys said the
same line to John that
said demands right before that happened
isn't their survival more important than
your pride isn't their survival more
important than your head and then for in
this episode there's another repeated
line from that episode this time from
John I wish you could fortune to the
wolves to comb nutrition this line was
mance rayder's final words to Stannis I
wish you good fortune in the wars to
come by the way this was also the line
that Sir Arthur Dayne told Ned Stark
before they fought at the Tower of joy I
wish you could put you in the wars to
come I think the show is using this line
to mean hey I respect you but my
loyalties lie with a greater cause and
then finally really the smoking gun
evidence that Daenerys is becoming
Stannis notice this line and I have
fewer enemies today than I did yesterday
ha ha ha hear that it sounds like
Stannis and Davos is grammer pet peeve
has spread to her two and less foolish
fingernails to clean fewer how many men
do we have in the north to fight in
10,000 less fewer well ok coming out of
this comparison it's interesting how
like Stannis Daenerys gets along well
with John but she also struggles with
helping John fight in the war to come
instead she's obsessed with getting the
Iron Throne but the irony of this is if
Daenerys had just allowed the tarly's to
take the black as Tyrion suggested she
would be helping her ally John she'd be
sending a ton of soldiers to the wall to
defend Westeros against the army of the
Dead
instead she decides that the power she
gets from the blood of the dragon is
more important to her now before we move
on I noticed something interesting about
Daenerys is clothing here so let's bring
back a favorite segment in these
breakdowns Game of Thrones fashion
roundup now I missed this last episode
and all the chaos and Dragon Fire of the
battle but Daenerys is wearing a
modified version of her apparel this
time it's aligned with fur you can see
it on the collar in the cuffs so I
assume they did this because yeah winter
is here and it's getting colder
everywhere but remember Daenerys just
flew here from Dragonstone onto the back
of a dragon so this outfit is kind of
like a flight jacket and while we're
discussing clothing we just learned from
costume designer Michelle Clapton that
she use drugs from Ikea for the furs of
the Nights Watch in fact I think we can
actually see some of these rugs in their
furs and the final shots of the episode
ok moving on
to Jamie and Cersei and Kings Landing
now notice when Cersei gets the bad news
both about losing her
me and the truth about Elena murdering
Joffrey she steps this that Jamie so we
fight and die or we submit and die I
know my choice so you should know yes so
by calling Jamie the soldier
I think Cersei is referencing the figure
of the warrior which is one of these
seven new gods the seven represent the
different personality types that people
in the society reflect we brought this
up before in the context of Arya
comparing heard of the stranger but in
this case Cersei is appealing to Jaime
to be the warrior a true fighter who
never hesitates actually later miss
episode Cersei changes her strategy to
appeal to Jaime as a different one of
the seven the father who uses his father
yeah now here's Cersei reveals to Jaime
that she's pregnant and that promise of
a new family bloodline motivates her to
allow Jaime to seek a deal with Tyrion
she's now concerned about the future
also for Jaime this would be the first
time he gets to be a true father and not
have to hide it from the world and from
the child him or herself but we should
acknowledge that not all may be what it
seems here Cersei could be faking this
pregnancy to manipulate Jaime Philip and
Monte got into all those interesting
theories in Westeros weekly so make sure
to check that out but here notice the
line that Cersei and Jaime used to
remember their father Tywin Lannister do
you remember what father used to say
about people the lion does not concern
himself with the opinions of the Sheep
I'm actually really glad the show
brought this up because it reminds us of
Tywin's amazing introductory scene to
the series back in season 1 when you
hear them whispering Kingslayer behind
your back doesn't it bother you
of course it bothers me the lion doesn't
concern himself with the opinions of the
Sheep
in that scene Tywin lectured Jamie on
the importance of the Lannister name and
bloodline how it's the only thing that
will survive after they're all dead and
now in this scene we're seeing that
wisdom echoing through Tywin's children
okay moving on back in Dragonstone we
get this amazing face-to-face encounter
between drogon and john now obviously
this is meant to foreshadow the
confirmation of John's lineage that we
get laid in this episode but I also
think it parallels another time a dragon
was surprisingly tame in the dungeons of
murine with Tyrion so if we assume that
the reason drogon is a
John to pet him is because John secretly
has the blood of the dragon running
through his veins does that mean that
Tyrion is also a part of this same
family bloodline now in the past we
brought up this theory that here Ian
Lannister might actually be the bastard
son of the Mad King who could have
conceived Tyrion with thailand's wife
Joanna Lannister that would definitely
explain why Tywin always treated Tyrion
as less than a son now if that were true
that could make Tyrion the third head of
the dragon along with Daenerys and Jon
but I will say I still think the
evidence of that being true is pretty
thin like we're gonna need Gilly to read
a few more books and let's be honest
Tyrion doesn't get to like horse pat
rhaegal and Viserion
you just unchain them and they were nice
enough to not eat him so maybe that
moment back in season six was just
showing Tyrion as being destined to be a
friend and Ally to the Targaryen as
opposed to an actual family member but
we will see now back to this moment
we've never seen a dragon up this close
before
these sense of scale in the way that
this shot is amazing you can see each
individual's scale of the Dragons skin
in detail as Jon brushes his hands over
them then Jon looks deeply into dragons
eye I've noticed how it has this
vertical pupil and in an additional
horizontal eyelid now that's called a
nictitating membrane I think I'm saying
that right it sounds dirty now all these
features are actually how a crocodiles
eye looks the designers clearly use that
as a visual model but really I think
this whole visual of a man nervously
interacting with a surprisingly docile
giant reptile this all feels familiar in
fact I think it was inspired by scenes
in Jurassic Park with the Triceratops
and the Brachiosaurus and when the t-rex
doesn't eat the lawyer no wait he he
does but also I think John's moment with
drogon here might be pulling from the
movie How to Train Your Dragon there's a
lot of similarities between this and the
dynamic with hiccup and toothless which
began as a super threatening
relationship but then over time became
something far more familiar really I
just hope that's a case because I really
like that movie and I wanted John to
ride a dragon now it's interesting here
that Daenerys brings up that time when
Davos accidentally let slip that John
got stabbed in the heart now remember
the possibility of Resurrection is
something that Daenerys has considered
before just like Jon Snow Danny's former
husband called Drogo was also mute neat
against and was stabbed in the torso in
later
from those wounds and Denarius resorted
to dark magic to try to bring him back
to life
oh this idea of John having done that
successfully is something that she's not
gonna shake but then we get this
dramatic turn of Jorah Mormont and I
like how that Dothraki was like dude
walk directly behind me so Khaleesi you
can't sue at first Oh My she's gonna be
so stoked now John here brings up the
fact that he served jurors Father Jew or
Mormont in the Nights Watch but one
thing that doesn't come up is the fact
that John possesses long claw that's the
Valyrian steel Mormont sword that was
technically Joris birthright now John
isn't carrying it this second because
the Dothraki confiscated their weapons
but according to some rumors there was
some scene that might have been deleted
from this episode or might be in the
next episode where John and Jorah talk
about this I don't know we'll see okay
moving on to the north where bran is
working through these Ravens like their
spy planes notice how their eyes quickly
go white and then back to normal kind of
like camera flashes as if he's toggling
around the different angles then when
the night king terrifyingly locks in on
him the Ravens scatter in Brants
connection is severed so what is going
on here now some people have suggested
that the night King might be a warg as
well and bran just signed out so that
the night king couldn't connect with his
consciousness through these Ravens I'm
not sure if that's a case I think we
would have seen the night Kings eyes
turn white but it is likely that the
night King has some supernatural power
for example he might have intentionally
jammed bran signal here scattering these
birds or maybe he just frightened brand
and brand decided to leave man come on
he's spooky okay moving on to Old Town
and we see the letter that Wilkins sent
them on branes behalf it's a little hard
to make out here but we do get a clear
shot of the version that was sent to
John later in Dragonstone so let's dive
into another favorite new rock star
segment zoom enhance okay let's see when
you flip it it kind of looks like John's
just holding out for us to read thanks
John okay let's see your brother bran
has returned from beyond the wall
possessed of super freaky abilities he
can see across vast distances though
only at the heart tree of Winterfell
yeah that sounds right he warns that the
army of the dead is marching on the wall
near East Watch by the Bell Missy and
maybe John's finger was covering the
part about Arya having returned because
I don't see that anywhere
anyway I assume the version that will
consent to the maesters included a bunch
of hilarious meister jokes like a few
disses to low dose maybe unload of but
also some requests to get the word out
to everyone else in Westeros
unfortunately pay close attention to the
tidbit that ebro's drops at the end of
the scene Ravan really was fooling about
last time I know it sounds like the
primary way that the Citadel
communicates with the rest of the world
the Raven ray is not the best condition
to get the word out about this army of
the Dead even if they wanted to but
these catty old masters dropped a few
other interesting details in this scene
if you listen closely it brings to mind
who our Co TV host owns the Charlatans
who claimed descent from the children of
the forest
don't forget the dog who promised that
the drowned God would rise up and
destroy Aegon the conquerer yeah we
heard we said old man so they just
referenced two figures from the history
of Westeros India Song of Ice and Fire
books which might have some bearing on
where the show is headed so let's dive
deep into these in a new thoughtful
segment that I'm calling well in the
book
okay so first one maester jokes about
Jenny of old stones well in the books
Jenny of old stones was a common woman
who married Duncan Targaryen who was
uncle to the Mad King but he gave up his
birthright by marrying this commoner now
Jenny of old stones is this mysterious
figure who they've written songs about
but she had a friend who was a wood
witch boom some book readers believe is
actually the same person as another
character in the books known as the
ghost of high hearts she's a tiny old
woman with red eyes who cryptically
predicts events of the future for the
Brotherhood in the Riverlands she
predicted the death of Baylon Greyjoy
and the emergence of Lady Stoneheart and
the fact that the prince or the princess
that was promised would be the
descendants of Eros and raela Targaryen
now what does any of this have to do
with the show
I think even mentioning Jenny of old
stones and her children of the fort's
connection could just be a throwaway
reference to this theory from the books
but knowing this show I think there's a
good chance it'll come into play so I
think these old a-holes in the Citadel
are going to be proven wrong and there
actually was someone descended from the
children of the forest somewhere in the
Riverlands
who's going to come into the show maybe
some adaptation of the ghost of
hi heart or the ghost of my heart
herself or some other new character who
will reveal a key insight about the
children of the forest and the White
Walkers
now the second alleged crackpot that
they bring up is low-dose who claimed
that the drowned God would rise up and
defeat Aegon the conquerer well in the
books Bo dose was king of the Iron
Islands during Aegon's conquest and he
claimed to be the son of the drowned God
he called upon the drowned God to send
his Krakens to sink Aegon's fleet and
when that didn't happen he filled his
pockets with stones and walked into the
sea to talk to his father and
unfortunately a lot of the good men and
women of Pike followed him into the sea
and for years their bodies kept washing
up on the shores and again these old
timers can laugh all they want but I
think some version of this prophecy may
end up coming true in fact think about
it
Daenerys is the descendant of Aegon the
Conqueror and she's almost exactly
following his footsteps of his conquest
meanwhile perhaps Daenerys his biggest
threat is the drowned God Joran Greyjoy
we don't know where his fleet is I
assume it's still laying siege to
Casterly Rock but honestly we have no
idea
he has zipped back and forth across
Westeros like it's nothing I actually
suspect that Cersei plans to use Euron
to undermine whatever agreement she
plans to make with Daenerys and if that
happens in a way it'll prove crazy old
low dose right the drowned God will have
risen up against this Targaryen dragon
Conqueror okay moving on to Dragonstone
and this interesting chat between tyrion
and varys
there's actually a second scene playing
out in the subtext if you pay attention
to the cup that the two of them are
drinking from but first we should talk
about Tyrians drinking tyrion loves
drink in fact the first time we see him
in season 1 he was shotgunning ale and
didn't join something else now over the
course of the series Tyrion has used
wine to hide his fear of responsibility
kind of like when you get loaded just to
you know numb them the shame of the
mistakes that you're inevitably gonna
make yeah I'm talking from experience
yeah I remember Tyrion got sloshed on
his wedding night with Sansa threatened
to castrate the king all because he
feared the responsibility of being a
husband in this forced political
marriage then later when Tyrion was in
exile Varys arrived and kind of took on
the role of an a a sponsor calling out
his drinking and pushing him to clean up
his act and play a role
in saving the realm you already drank
yourself across the Narrow Sea in the
books why stop now
last season Tyrians drinking persisted
when Daenerys disappeared in Mereen was
left to him to run in fact he could say
that recklessness ended with that bad
deal with the slavers when they betrayed
him and this season until this point we
actually haven't seen Tyrion drink
on-screen at all now I'm being technical
here he was holding some wine at the
beginning of episode 2 but he walked out
of frame before we saw him actually sip
it regardless he's been arguably more
sober this season than ever before but
now after seeing his family's army
turned to ash he needs a stiff drink
beerus is back in the role of a a
sponsor he snatches a cup away from
Tyrion he sips it and winces because he
doesn't like the taste of wine but he
downs it anyway so that Tyrion can't now
of course hearing just refills a cup but
bears his point is clear here Daenerys
is not her father
and she never will be with the right
counsel you need to find a way to make
her listen
beerus needs Tyrion to stay sober to be
a good adviser to Daenerys ok next up in
Aegon
you look at the table you can see how
last episodes dragon battle realigned
the map you can see one of the dragon
figures alongside a Dothraki horse head
between Highgarden and King's Landing
meanwhile the Lannister lions have been
completely taken off the map meanwhile
it looks like that unsullied helmet is
still over at Casterly Rock so I'm
guessing in their trap there but they
still haven't lost the city now Tyrians
big plan to capture one white and bring
it down to Cersei as proof that the
White Walkers exist is actually that's
something that's been tried before
remember there was the white that
attacked Lord Commander Mormont and Jon
Snow at Castle black now in the books
Mormont
ordered Alliser thorne to take the
whites twitching severed hand to King's
Landing now the show don't really get
into it but in a clash of kings
Tyrion as hand of the king laughs with
bran about how thorne brought a hand in
a jar that was just rotting away and
they more or less turned him away but
now that Tyrion believes in White
Walkers existence he's willing to try it
again but this time with a full live ish
corpse that hopefully won't rot before
it arrives
ok fast-forwarding through Sansa and
Arya butting heads a little in
Winterfell we move on to King
landing we're Tyrion reunites with Jamie
in the red key basement where Aegon's
dragon skulls are stored now it's
interesting that Tyrion chose this
setting now of course it's a relatively
discreet spot for a secret rendezvous
but also considering he just saw his
brother go down hard against Daenerys
his dragon surrounding Jaime now with
these massive dragon skulls seems like
it could be a Power Move by Tyrion he's
reminded Jaime exactly how much of a
disadvantage he's at and how desperately
he needs to make a deal with him now
let's move on to flea bottom where Davos
finds an old face whom we predicted
might come back to season injury and I
like other writers worked in this joke
thought you might still be ruling and
yeah that's a meta joke about how weird
it was that they left off with Gendry
just rowing away at the end of season 3
and never bothered to check in with him
again but he's back now and yeah we've
never seen Gendry this gung-ho it seems
like learning the truth that his father
was the great Robert Baratheon has
clearly inspired him he is definitely
his father's son he secretly hates
making weapons with the Lannisters and
he's ready to jump in the battle at a
moment's notice just leave everything
behind and most importantly his weapon
of choice is the Warhammer of course
Robert Baratheon famously used his
Warhammer in his rebellion using it to
crush Rhaegar Targaryen at the Trident
and yeah thankfully we get to see
ginjury put some awesome practice swings
on this thing and actually notice what
alias Davos uses to hide Kendra's real
name I told you Clovis if we don't get
out of here soon okay so Clovis is a
weirdly specific name choice and for all
you history buffs
you may recognize that it has roots in
real world history so let us dive
together into the annals of history
maybe we should change that name I don't
want to dive into ok anyway Clovis could
be a reference to the Clovis period in
early human history it's named for the
Clovis weaponry which consisted largely
of arrowheads and spear heads this could
be the show's way of saying that Gendry
might be putting his Smith's skills to
work recreating the ancient dragonglass
weapons that the first men used to get
the White Walkers
but Clovis has another meaning it was
also the name of the first king of the
Franks in the Middle Ages this was in
the aftermath of the Roman Empire Clovis
United all the Frankish tribes into one
ruler and established the Merovingian
dynasty essentially creating the whole
system of a monarchy in early France and
I could see something like that being in
the cards for Gendry as well Robert
Baratheon's only true born son who's
still alive carrying out his legacy of a
real Baratheon dynasty that he never got
to see when he was alive okay before I
move on you may have noticed that the
actor playing this gold cloak this is
the same guy who played the actor
playing Ned Stark in that play that Arya
watched last season in Braavos now this
isn't the first time the show has reused
actors like this the actor who played
Tommen used to be Martyn Lannister from
season three just something I realized
way too late all right moving back to
Dragonstone and I don't know what it is
about Jon and caves guys but he really
hits it off with people in these things
the immediate mutual respect between
John and Gendry isn't a coincidence Mac
notice how Gentry says this my father's
trusted each other emotionally now of
course if we're being technical with
Jon's biological father
ginger II couldn't be more wrong Robert
and Rhaegar hated each other but come on
since Gendry is clearly referring to
Robert in Ned he's totally right and
back notice their exchange here I saw
your father once at Winterfell
I met yours in my shop
you're a lot leaner you're a lot shorter
these friendly jabs totally mirror the
ones between Robert and Ned in the very
first episode you've got fat
I'm just excited to see the spirit of
Ned and Robert's friendship living on in
their bastard sons
now speaking of John's lineage we got to
move on to the Sept of Baelor sighs
bombshell that this episode dropped with
Gilly telling us crucial information in
that Sam doesn't care about but does
unknown mean it's when a man sets aside
his lawful wife Maynard says here that
he issued an annulment for Prince
Rhaegar and remarried him to someone
else at the same time in a secret
ceremony in Dorne
seven hells did the show really expect
us to not immediately understand how big
of a deal this is okay Syria laughing
along nervously but are secretly
confused this record kept by the
apparently very regular Septon Maynard
is definitive proof that Rhaegar
Targaryen marriage with Elia Martell was
annulled so that his marriage with
Lyanna stark could be legal and that Jon
Snow is the illegitimate born son not a
bastard and thus true heir to the Iron
Throne now that point is technically
debatable Phillip Ahmad actually
explained all these details in westeros
weekly so go check that out now when Sam
decides to leave the Citadel notice what
he says to Gilly here
I'm tired of reading about the
achievements of better men now Sam is
quoting his father the late Lord randyll
Tarly who actually said the same thing
to him last season at horn health
spending your lives reading about the
achievements of better men and it's
interesting that Sam brings up his
father here because now that his father
and brother are dead even though he
doesn't know it the future of house
Tarly is now firmly on Sam's shoulders
and remember he also currently possesses
the Tarly family Valyrian steel sword
hearts fame Sam has quickly gone to
Tarly number one now I also want to
point out how much Sam's journey
surprisingly matches a famous character
from this show Ned Stark now I know the
two men aren't that similar but think
about it one the two men were both
highborn second sons who took on the
responsibilities of their house
after their fathers and older brothers
were burned to death by a Targaryen both
Sam and Ned travelled south to a place
that they didn't fit in with at all and
they both uncovered crush
truths by reading ancient texts that no
one else bothered to look at and pretty
crazy coincidence both of these men
returned to their homes with baby boys
whom they claimed were their bastards
even though they weren't just to protect
the boys so really by leaving Old Town
behind Sam is pursuing a destiny that
Ned Stark never really could kind of
like Daenerys with Stannis and Gendry
with Robert this younger generation is
avoiding the mistakes made by their
spiritual forbearers okay moving on to
Winterfell where Arya spies on Petyr
Baelish
now the scroll that he received from
maester wolkan was actually set up back
in episode three remember there was that
intrigued glance when woken brought up
luhan's old records no I'll check my
saloons Rachel chief kept a copy of
every raven scroll and then when Arya
searches its chamber she knows to check
the mattress and this is actually a
super subtle callback to season 3 Santa
told Tyrion about a prank he could play
to get revenge on an enemy he cost a
little hole in his mattress and you
stuff sheep dung inside and you show up
to the hole and make his bed again he's
really stink he might know where it's
coming from
lady Sansa my sister used to do that
when she was angry with me
oh yeah basically Arya left all these
little [ __ ] holes and mattresses all
over Winterfell so she knows it's the
perfect place to hide something now
taking a look at this scroll we're gonna
need another round of zoom in it oh I
guess the show already kind of zoomed
and enhanced for us now we can't see all
of the letter here but we have already
seen this letter on the show before in
season 1 Cersei and Petyr Baelish more
or less forced Sansa to write this
letter to her brother Rob tell him to
come to King's Landing and swear his
fealty to Joffrey some sort others it is
your sister's hand but the Queen's words
and based on Littlefinger suspicious
look as Arya leaves his chamber clearly
he's using this old letter to try to
turn Arya against her sister by making
Arya think that Sansa betrayed her
family in favor of the Lannisters but my
opinion this isn't gonna work
Arya is smarter than this remember in
Braavos when that wave was stalking her
she was able to outsmart the way--the
and lure her into her own trap hey guys
we just saw her infiltrate the twins and
take out the entire House Frey now Petyr
Baelish maybe the cleverest enemy are
has ever faced but I wouldn't be
surprised if there was another layer to
the Spy vs spy game between the two of
them and that aria knows that little
fingers trying to trick her so she's
tricking Littlefinger who's trying to
trick her and she's trying to trick him
back and there's it's sure exception oh
okay the final scenes take place at the
namesake of this episode
eastwatch-by-the-sea the castle on a far
eastern edge of the wall now when Torben
takes John and the rest to see the
Brotherhood I love all they all pretty
much immediately recognized the
different ways they know and hate each
other but it was interesting that Jorah
recognized thoughts of mirror Thoris
well oddly recognize Jim now for a
second we're all like how these guys
know each other books going to the
backstory in greater detail but if you
remember in season 3 Jorah actually told
us in Barristan Selmy all about his
exploits or thoris when they see spike
in the first grade joy rebellion Thorson
here went in alone waving that flaming
sword of his Robert knighted you after
the battle by this moment of my life
then beric Dondarrion says this
interesting line hugh hola at the edge
of the world at the same moment heading
in the same direction for the same
reason the world is also the title of a
text written by maester Balder about his
time serving the Nights Watch at
eastwatch-by-the-sea now guys this
motley crew is really the best fantasy
team of Fighters that you would want to
see on any mission on the show in fact
four of them are men who more or less
have come back from the dead now they
are fighting the dead and the fact that
there are seven of them may be a
reference to the Magnificent Seven or
the Seven Samurai the Akira Kurosawa
film that it was based on now both these
films are classics and they're stories
about seven eclectic warriors who
overcome their infighting for a noble
cause of course we'll see more of this
a-team next episode but I assume that's
how it's gonna go down I also think
there's a deeper significance to the
number seven here so let's activate a
late in the episode theory time okay so
you may have noticed that these seven
men kind of correspond to these seven
new gods the father the mother the Crone
the maiden the warrior the Smith and a
stranger and what I love about this is
that what's set up next week's conflict
as new versus old the new gods versus
the old gods of the north the magic of
the children of the forest in the four
of the army of the Dead okay so who's
who the father represents justice now
you could say this is John who's the
leader of the pack
he kind of fits that role but personally
I think beric Dondarrion is a more
accurate father type look back on all of
his episodes he's always been the
purveyor of justice
in season three he allowed the Hound to
a trial by combat and then later when we
rejoined him in season six he was
hanging bandits for what they did to
brother ray and his people okay next the
mother represents mercy now not many of
these characters have been that merciful
except John he showed the mothers mercy
even when it cost him the trust of his
own people he spared Mance Rayder a
painful death he rescued wild lanes at
hardhome and recently he pardoned to the
Karstark and umber children okay next up
the Crone represents wisdom and
foresight and yeah I would say Thoris of
mere fits that description best as an
agent of the Lord of Light he recently
helped the hound see his destiny in the
flames total Crone now all of these men
could be the warrior back that's
probably the one they'd all called dibs
on the warrior of course represents
fierceness in battle and really mostly
because this character doesn't fit
really any of the other personality
types of the seven I think
tormund Giantsbane is the purest warrior
of this bunch okay next the maiden
represents purity and innocence and out
of all of these characters the youngest
most innocent and the most untested of
them is Gendry now I know what you're
saying
Gendry is literally a Smith so you think
he'd be the Smith but I actually think
the Hound is a better fit for this myth
because the Smith represents labor and
when sander came back to the show last
season what was he doing he was building
a cept manual labor
his whole thing now is to try to be
constructive after spending so many
years destroying things so spiritually
at least I think the Hound is more of a
Smith than any of these others now that
leaves us with the stranger the figure
clouded a mystery who represents death
now of this seven Jorah Mormont is the
closest to the stranger since his exile
from Westeros he has wandered the lands
shifting loyalties and often bringing
death and yeah guys his greyscale made
him pretty unrecognizable at the
beginning of the season now that's just
my interpretation of it but let me know
how you would cast these men into the
different roles down in the comments but
for now let's move on to our closing
images now the dream team here is
heading north with John leading the pack
I love this shot remember this
episode's original title was blood of
the Dragon and even though John doesn't
yet realize it his Targaryen bloodline
is definitely giving him power here he
was just face to face with a dragon and
he can face whatever waits for him
beyond the wall hopefully but it's not
just John who's driving power from
family bloodlines Daenerys got her power
by embracing Elena's advice to be the
dragon allowing herself to briefly
follow in the footsteps of her father
the Mad King in order to force her
enemies to bend the knee Cersei uses the
power of family bloodlines on Jaime
revealing her pregnancy and the future
of a Lannister bloodline to emotionally
manipulate him also remember arya points
out how Sansa is getting power from her
connection to her mother and father by
moving into their chamber and Tyrion
upon feeling like a traitor to his
bloodline now appeals to the only
remaining family connection that means
anything his brother Jaime to redeem
himself as a useful end boy for Daenerys
after his bloodline is nearly erased
Samwell Tarly leaves old town more
empowered than ever ready to carry on
the Tarly family name and long lost sons
Gendry and Jorah returned to the fold
empowered by the memories of their
fathers to now carry the torch for their
own bloodline now this season has spent
a lot of time showing characters trying
to disassociate themselves from the sins
of their fathers but now family is a
source of strength and blood of the
Dragon now that we know that John was a
legitimate birth do you think his claim
to the throne will be recognized do you
think Arya is getting played by
Littlefinger or do you think she is
playing him do you think there was any
significance to those maesters
mentioning Jenny of old stones and
low-dose and do you think Daenerys is
losing herself by going through with
burning the tarly's alive tell me in the
comments below or tweet at me at EA boss
or at new rockstars at new rockstars and
if you do tweet us your questions make
sure to use the hashtag Westeros weekly
so that we'll see it maybe feature it in
our videos and if you like you can
contribute to us on patreon to help us
make more videos big thanks to all of
our donors especially Allen Fleming your
awesome man thanks for watching and see
you next week bye